in the second part of the Communist
Manifesto there's really two main things
that are that are going on there two
main projects one of them is to answer
some of the objections to to communism
and we're going to look at each one of
these objections and the Marxist or
communist response that's articulated in
there which is going to show us a bit
more about the philosophical perspective
that is being articulated here but
before that what we want to look at is
the the other thing that's going on and
what they're doing is they're
articulating the relationship between
the Communist Party
proletarians in politics the the
Communist Party is in fact a political
party although at the time that this is
being written and for quite a while
afterwards actually still in some
countries it has to be underground it
can't be an official party in some
places triumph to become the only
official party of course and the
Communist Party is intended to provide
the the venue and what they call the
Vanguard for the political action of
this class of the proletariat the
working class so when they're writing
this they begin with the question what
relation to the Communist and of the
proletarians as a whole and they say
we're a party unlike the other parties
we're not tied to just one single nation
we have no interest separate from and
apart from the proletariat as a whole
and they talk about the Communists as
bringing to the front the common
interest of the entire proletariat so
not just the German proletariat or the
Argentinian proletariat or the Chinese
proletariat or the American proletariat
the working people everywhere that's one
reason why the Communists are gonna be
saying things like working people the
world unite yeah they say also that they
always in everywhere represent the
interests of the movement
as a whole so this is a way for the
Communists to assert that they are
looking out for the proletariat more
than anybody else is and the question is
you know whether they can make good on
that claim he goes on and he says that
they're the most advanced and resolute
section of the working-class parties of
every country the section which pushes
forward all the others you know and
historically that sometimes actually the
case that the Communist Party would be
one of the main parties on the left on
the the progressive or the revolutionary
side they would they would help to draw
the other parties to them by being the
most extreme and they says that they
also have over the great mass of the
proletariat advantage of clearly
understanding the line of mark where
they're going the conditions and the
ultimate general results of the
proletarian movement so what's going on
at the time is there's a lot of ferment
there's a lot of action on the part of
parties of the proletariat and the
Communists are saying were the ones that
actually have the best view about where
we're supposed to be going so where are
they intending to go they actually do
intend to abolish bourgeois property and
do a lot of these other things as well
these objections are going to get
explained but usually Marx is going to
say well you know we are going to do
this but it should be understood in this
way so you know make no bones about it
one thing that the Communists are saying
that they're going to do in this is
they're going to if they take power
they're going to abolish bourgeois
property relations bourgeois means of
production they're going to centralize
the the means of production in the hands
of the state and the state will be
serving the proletariat so that the
state will be sort of the stand-in for
the the current market-based economy
that's one thing that they clearly
intend if you look through those numbers
points towards the very end of this this
section abolition of property and land
and application of all rents of land to
to public purposes so this would be
saying for example apartments you know
you would rent your apartment from the
state and all of those rents would be
going in to support the the working
class
have you progressive or graduated income
tax what kind of meanness were not the
only people advocating that abolition of
all rights of inheritance this is a way
to try to break up long-standing ruling
families who who used wealth to do that
centralization of credit in the hands of
the state by means of a natural bank
with state capital and an exclusive
monopoly then this gives you an idea of
what it is that these these people are
proposing
so let's look now at the objections to
this this whole program the Communists
are saying that the they're going to
abolish existing property relations but
those existing property relations are
bourgeois property relations and this is
one of the the concerns that people have
are you going to get rid of private
property altogether the Communist study
yes but we're not getting rid of
property altogether because the
bourgeois have actually got rid of
previous property relations as they
consolidated their power both culturally
economically politically socially in
terms of the educational institutions
the very ideas that people are working
with they've abolished other types of
property and we're talking now Marx is
saying about doing the same thing so he
says the French Revolution for example
abolished feudal property the property
of the aristocrats the nobles in favor
of bourgeois property so he says the
distinguishing feature of communism is
not the abolition of property generally
but the abolition of bourgeois property
so what does it actually mean he's using
this phrase now bourgeois property and
we want to take a look at how this is
explained here so that you can clearly
understand what it is that he's
suggesting and why he's he's proposing
it so he says communists have been
repelled
with the desire of abolishing the right
of personally acquiring property as the
fruit of a man's own labour which
property is alleged to be the groundwork
of all personal freedom activity and
independence and this is a long-standing
notion you can see this in previous
thinkers and you can see people still
making recourse to this sort of notion
today that where property really comes
from it is the investment of labour
applied to some sort of raw materials on
the part of the person who works and
property is you might say the reward or
the the product whatever it is the thing
that comes about and whatever labor they
put into it they get it property so if
you have a field and you put in two
hours a day taking care of your field
but your neighbor puts in eight hours a
day and their harvest is way better than
yours you don't get the complaint and
say hey why don't we share it all you
know equal with each other because the
other guy can say buddy I put in eight
hours you are sitting around taking it
easy all the time when I was out there
sweating in the Sun I deserve to have
more property and mark says you know
what that really is
that's not bourgeois property that's pre
bourgeois property that's the sort of
thing that people did in fact do people
who say you know claimed land and
improved the land and it therefore
became theirs to work people who had a
farm people who were doing handiwork
people who are primitive artisans all of
that really does does make sense that's
not what happens in bourgeois society
though that's not what happens with the
new mode of production what he's calling
bourgeois property works like this
though the proletariat puts in a certain
amount of labour and of that labor it
generates a given amount of property or
wealth or product however you want to
understand it some of that goes to
maintaining the proletariat so he'll
talk about a minimum wage and what is
the minimum wage understood to be in
those times well you know it's kind of
similar to our understanding of minimum
wage now what do you need in order to
actually survive you know we raise the
minimum wage because we say well you
know somebody who's providing for a
family of four can't make it on X amount
of money per hour for something they
need you know 20 cents more or two
dollars more or whatever the the basic
idea is well what is the minimum that
you can pay somebody so that they will
actually still be able to show up to
work the next day to make you some more
money because notice that what you're
not paying to the proletariat it becomes
a surplus that's your profit that's what
you take if you're the one who owns the
means of production if you're the one
who's putting other people to work and
directing them the word for that Marx's
capital this is where capitalism comes
from capital is not just the money that
you're able to invest your capital
investment in some sort of concern where
did that actually come from in the first
place it came from shortchanging
somebody else on the work that they're
putting in taking oftentimes the great
you know majority of what it is that
they're able to generate and giving them
just enough to keep clothed fed living
and reproducing maybe enough to get
drunk every once in a while so that
they'll blossom steaming leaving a long
this surplus capital then is able to get
reinvested back into the process this is
where it gets really interesting and
really important to think in terms long
term processes what happens if we go
through a number of iterations of this
where the laborer is generating X amount
of wealth or value and they're getting
only a minimal amount in return
they get poorer and poorer in relation
to the bourgeois who ends up ending more
and more and more and more because this
capital allows them to have control over
other people it's what that allows them
to set up this very system in the first
place and to say you know I was doing
pretty good here now let me expand over
there I have five workers and I'm you
know taking say three workers worth of
labor in as my capital my surplus from
them and the rest of it's going to keep
them fed and housed and stuff like that
if I seem a little bit from the work
that they're doing I can hire ten people
then I can hire 20 people then I can
hire a hundred people same thing by the
way it Marx thinks goes for rent rental
properties work like this same thing
works by the way also for the credit
system there's a lot of applications to
this life so after all this is in it you
know in your in your mind mark says hard
work how hard one self acquired self
rent property do you mean the property
of the petty artisan of the small
peasant a form of property that preceded
the bourgeois form there's no need to
abolish that the development of industry
is destroying that every day there's
fewer and fewer opportunities for
somebody to actually make it on their
own as what we would nowadays call a
small business owner who doesn't have
any other employees who's providing all
of us themselves do you mean bourgeois
modern private property and then mark
says exactly what we're saying here does
wage labor actually create any property
for the labourer
not a bit now you might object and say
yeah but you know you work in the
factory and you're able to buy yourself
a car and a TV and you know
have a 20-year 30-year mortgage and
eventually you got your house and
there's a truth to that
however in relation to the vast amounts
of wealth that are being generated over
here and constantly being reinvested and
grown that's not much to have that's
just enough to keep on going to keep on
living it's not enough to provide the
kind of life that the the worker
actually deserves in part because
they're generating it for other people
it says property in its present form is
based on the antagonism of capital and
wage-labour so let's actually examine
both sides of this he says to be a
capitalist is not only to have a purely
personal but a social status and
production here's what's actually being
denied here this is all social meaning
that it's part of social processes the
reason why a factory owner can actually
operate his or her factory and hire
people is because there's a whole bunch
of things in society actually propping
that up and making it possible for them
to do that there is no such thing
according to Marx within bourgeois
property as the self-made man there is
in pre bourgeois property but that
becomes rarer and rarer and rarer and
one of the things that people often do
is a Tate bourgeois property and they
pretend like it's pre-modern property
when it's not really so so it says
capital is a social power when capital
is converted into common property into
the property of all the members of
society personal property is not
transformed into social property it's
only putting it back where it was
originally it loses its class character
so he says let's now take wage labour
the average price is the minimum wage so
whatever the worker is getting by his or
her labor they're never able to get
ahead as a matter of fact they're
falling further and further behind the
entire time so in bourgeois
Society what does this tell you about
people living labor is but it means to
increase accumulated labour what does
that mean the living labor that's going
into creating this wealth here is being
put back into the system to now create
mechanisms of control over that very
labor in communist Society says
accumulated labor is but it means to
widen to enrich to promote the existence
of the labor so now notice what he's
saying here is that if we're going to
switch from bourgeois property to
communist property you're not going back
to this you're actually still
maintaining some sort of surplus but
that surplus would now go back in part
into here even better wages and the
surplus is going back into taking care
of the condition of the laborer so
instead of making somebody's mansion
bigger it builds a park instead of
putting a new brick face on the bank
maybe it creates a new Coliseum where
people can go and not pay eighty bucks a
ticket or whatever it is to go see a
sporting event but go for free the idea
is that you still have some sort of
surplus being generated but that surplus
is being used for socially useful ends
for the benefit of the working class not
for the benefit of the ruling
parasitical capitalist class so he goes
on he says another way to think about
this in bourgeois society the past
dominates the present the fact that you
took surplus capital out from before and
now you have wealth and now you can
reinvest it means that the past
dominates the present in cognitive
society the present dominates the past
you're replacing the old ways in words
on society capital is independent and
has individuality but what about the
living person the living person is
depend
it has no individuality so it radically
changes the ordering between wealth and
people people should be higher than
wealth
according to to those of you so what do
we have to say about this mark says yes
we do intend to abolish property
bourgeois property we're gonna make
social property social and he points out
a few other things too he says you know
if you're gonna criticize us for
abolishing private property keep in mind
not everybody has private property as a
matter of fact most people don't he says
in your existing society private
property has already done a way for
we've done away with for nine-tenths of
the population its existence for the few
is due to its non-existence in the hands
of those 9/10 so if we're abolishing it
it's not really hurting other people so
much because we're actually doing
something that's good for the majority
another interesting objection that he
considers with respect to that is that
if we abolish property altogether then
nobody's going to work this actually did
turn out to be a problem in some
communist countries by the way Marx says
well you know if that's really your
logic then follow that through does the
bourgeois work know he benefits but any
benefits from somebody else doing the
work which then if you want to call you
know reinvesting proceeds work but it's
not really work it's not really hard
labor the bourgeois is doing things and
he doesn't have to work so if we abolish
property we're not going to bring about
universal laziness or a sloth what are
some other objections culture is going
to disappear so he says there's going to
be a disappearance of class culture
which
is for the bourgeois identical with the
disappearance of all culture nobody is
going to play symphonies anymore
everybody's just gonna sit around and
blow in jugs or whatever the lowest
common denominator happens to be nobody
is gonna write plays nobody's gonna
write novels nobody will even produce TV
shows that you watch on your Netflix
because those are those require capital
investments those require actors who get
paid to do work those require writers
and directors and all these that you
know sound people and lighting people so
if we're going to get rid of property
that means intellectual property is
going to vanish as well mark says no
you're just going to get rid of
bourgeois intellectual property and he
points out the culture the loss of which
the bourgeois the mess is for the
enormous majority a mere training to act
as a machine to fit into the system to
be a good producer and not make any
waves not demand more for yourself so he
goes that money says don't wrangle with
us as long as you apply the standard of
your bourgeois notions of freedom or
culture or law your very ideas are just
the outgrowth of the conditions of your
bourgeois production and bourgeois
property just as your jurisprudence your
legal system is just the will of your
class made into a law for all a we lose
essential character and Direction are
determined by the economical conditions
of existence of your class and what
we're talking about there is a criticism
that what we're dealing with here is
actually etiology it's not culture as
such it's something that is determined
by the class process it's to the benefit
of the bourgeoisie it's to the detriment
of everybody else
he actually criticizes the bourgeois
moment of education at a certain point
and there's a lot of other people who
make similar complaints even down to the
present day the education might be
understood as you know public education
it has just
producing people that will fit into the
economy and not make any trouble and
work without demanding much in return
here's a really interesting criticism
you communists intend to abolish the
family and the family was looked at as
being a very important part of not only
society but individual people's lives so
you're going to get rid of the family
altogether
is that is that really the case for the
Communists and Marx says well yes and no
to some degree so he says what is the
present family the bourgeois family
based on what's its actual basis capital
private gain what allows you to to have
a family to be able to get married to
have a household to raise children to
buy them all the sort of things that
they want you know the very important
things that they need and the crap that
they don't need that the other kids
convince them that they need or they
convince themselves all that sort of
stuff you need to have some money you
need to be deriving capital from
somebody else in order to do that to
really live the kind of life that the
bourgeois are about you need some some
wealth what is it like for other people
in bourgeois society he says there's a
practical absence of the family among
the proletarians worse this is not as
big of an issue in our time as it was
back then there's public prostitution
there's a lot of young women very often
from working-class families who wind up
becoming prostitutes because there
aren't any other avenues open for them
other than destitution wages at the
middle and they have no legal protection
their lives are pretty short they have
to prostitute themselves that is subject
themselves to the Wills of other people
constantly and so Marx says you know
again for for the bourgeois this is
going to be a loss I admit that but for
everybody else they're already in a bad
condition as far as the family goes
see and then he says do you charge us
with wanting to stop the exploitation of
children child labor was a common thing
at that time and child labor had
blossomed in part because you could pay
children less than you had to pay adults
so Marx is saying hey if you're going to
like have a regime of child labor don't
talk to me about breaking up the family
you know the guys who are lucky enough
to have a family that looks out for them
and doesn't make them work in the mills
when they're 12 you know or six or
whatever they'll figure out what to do
we want to you know we want to
ameliorate the condition of these poor
kids or a stock in labor in their
childhood he talks about education as
well another interesting thing that he
talks about and I think this is a little
bit far-fetched
he says the bourgeois season his wife a
mere instrument of production and and
one of the things that the communist got
accused of was being into community and
women that you know you understand that
it's sort of wife swapping and Marx you
know and Engels actually take this on
and say well you know you bourgeois
you're doing that already because you
sleep with each other's wives I think
that this is probably one of those
sections where you know if you reverse
it and you think about the women's side
of this what they're saying becomes
rather unsavory that it just have this
open community now if you understand in
terms of freedom and the right to adopt
whatever partners you want with a
coercion or something like that then
perhaps they can I mean I start
advocating something better than the
bourgeois at the time do another issue
that they're talking about that the
Communists intend to abolish nationality
and it's important to remember that this
is being written in the 19th century
which in many respects was then the
century of nationalism when people
identified with I am a Frenchman I am
English
I am Welsh I am this I am that and there
is a growing sense of the importance of
the nation the Communists
say that nation's actually don't matter
that much why because the bourgeois
processes these processes of production
are homogenizing culture from country to
country to country the proletariat as
they say doesn't actually have a country
people who have a country are people who
can afford to have a country who are
benefiting from the current social
structure who can have their country
intervene on their part if they're you
know unfortunate enough to be caught off
guard while they're traveling the
proletariat don't travel they don't take
trips they don't go outside of where
they are because they have to work all
the time the last interesting discussion
has to do with a denial of eternal truth
and once again we're dealing with the
question of ideology so he says does it
require deep intuition to comprehend
that man's ideas views of conception in
one word man's consciousness changes
with every change in the conditions of
his material existence in his social
relations and his social life so Marx is
saying our consciousness our way of
thinking about things changes depending
on our economic conditions whether we
work whether we don't work how we work
whether we're exploited whether we're
being treated fairly and the rest of our
social life as well so he says if we
look at the history of ideas what we see
is that as we move from era to era we're
moving from one set of social relations
and economic relations to another set
and we can observe for example in the
realm of ideas ancient religion gets
replaced by an ancient philosophy as
well to a large extent by Christianity
and so the Middle Ages are a Christian
era and then after that we have the
modern era and we have a shift away from
Christianity to rationalist ideas and
the French Revolution is a great example
of that he says in that feudal society
for its death battle with the
revolutionary bourgeoisie one class was
for the older ideas the other class is
for the newer ideas and the class that
wins
their ideas went so he says here's what
a critic might say undoubtably religious
moral philosophical and juridical ideas
have been changed in the course of
historical development there's been some
modification but religion is such
morality philosophy political science
and law those survive this change
there's something eternal about them it
may be that they have slightly different
content but but people are still doing
philosophy people are still practicing
law and they says there are besides
eternal truths like freedom or justice
that are coming to all states of society
but communism denies eternal truths so
it's going to go against something that
is at the very root of what we are as
human beings Marxist Marx and Engels
response is that look every society has
been beset by class antagonisms we
haven't had one yet that doesn't have
classes exploiting each other fighting
against each other struggling to be free
so he says no wonder then that the
social consciousness of past ages
displayed all the despite all the
multiplicity and variety it displays
moves within certain common forms or
general ideas these eternal truths which
cannot completely vanish except with the
disappearance of class antagonisms so
until the political aspirations of the
Communist Party on behalf of the
proletariat are realized and bourgeois
property has been abolished property
relations of that sort of then you know
changed into something that's socially
beneficial we are always going to keep
having these ideas but that's not a good
reason for keeping those ideas if we
move to the classless society this is
again their viewpoint then these will
all become moot points so what we see
here is you know very strong
set of objections being raised and an
equally strong set of rebuttals or
responses which give us a better
understanding of what it is that the
Communists are proposing for the future
of human beings